[Musique]
mon coeur est brisé
c'est intéresse pas à moi pourquoi mes
parents se sont séparés au score je
devenir four
mon cerveau va éclater chers parents je
vous aime si fort que mon coeur va se
casser en deux tu vas chercher les
enfants à l'école ici sourit pop et déjà
s'il sourit pas souvent alors quand ils
voient pas et il ya quelque chose qui va
pas méchante et un monument joseph
botelho est fleuriste
ce père de deux enfants et séparée
depuis trois ans entre lui et son ex
la situation est rapidement devenue
tendue c'était le changement de
communication
on n'était pas capable de s'exprimer est
ce qu'on voulait et puis c'est comme une
grosse grosse jeu passant de vous les
donner c'est une question de contrôle
les positions sont campés donc on s'est
dit que peut-être il faut mettre en
place quelque chose donc pour les
coacher bonsoir bienvenue lorraine
fillion est travailleuse sociale au
cours de sa carrière elle a rencontré
des centaines de couples séparés dans
certains cas c'est la colère les enfants
souffrent elle a donc créé avec sa
collègue avocate frédéric lavoie un
cours pour réapprendre aux parents un
communiqué
pour le confesseur il faut que l'on peut
se parler compromis pour en venir à une
entente juste un équilibre c'est quoi
les faits du conflit qui finit plus de
finir
donc oui ça a fait que les enfants et ça
veut pas dire que l'enfant vont
nécessairement être témoin de chicane
ils peuvent manquer de confiance en eux
ils peuvent se laisser envahir par les
émotions quand son fût vieux les pré
ados et ados peuvent adopter des
comportements à risque
ils disent qu'ils aiment leurs enfants
et on n'en doute pas mais ils sont
souffrants et des fois leur souffrance
par rapport à l'autre faure omnibulée
complètement effectivement la prise en
compte des besoins de l'enfant
joseph voulait protéger ses enfants
sur les conseils de son avocat il a
participé aux ateliers de lorraine
filion c'était une chose que l'humour
monex vous voulez toujours le bien les
enfants fait que en usine que kim - mais
il ya certains cas dans la télé d'autres
coptes étaient envoyés que c'était
vraiment un port de la mer avec les
enfants on va leur faire faire des jeux
de rôles donc c'est des scénarios
simulés bonjour c'est josé j'aimerais te
demander ma famille à vient de rimouski
puis à voudrait voir les enfants pendant
que c'est la semaine de relâche est
souvent les parents se reconnaissent là
d'un très très bien pu y vont en
rajouter dans leur vie personnelle a
refait merci et on va leur faire faire
aussi des exercices 2 par 2 3 par 3 en
privé les parents adorent ça parce que
ils vont bien cotée entre eux ils vont
partager entre une leur situation
personnelle ils vont ce conseiller
et les parents ont tendance à bien
écouter un autre parent vient comme
l'impossibilité que des fois un
pansement comme ça puis on ne regarde
pas les autres options d'avoir des
personnes autour de nous
d'autres idées à beaucoup aidé la
majorité des parents qui viennent
ces volontaires mais ils ont des fois
des suggestions qui vont nous dire forte
forte ça peut être soit d'un juge qui
siège en matière familiale où le juge de
la jeunesse
ça peut être la direction de la
protection de la jeunesse appel l'avocat
et ça c'est vraiment chouette ça peut
être le psychologue qui suit la famille
où ils disent bon ce serait vraiment
important que vous ayez travaillé cette
communication l'a ensuite scandé vrai
dire mais ça ça différemment où ça sort
tout le monde est rarement souvent
c'était de reprendre le pont trop vite
des fois on reçoit un texte répond
immédiatement puis en étant en colère
qui ont répandu texte
on devrait peut-être pas envie arrêtez
de vous engager au téléphone et dans la
rue l'amour est fragile comme un pacs au
fil des années lauren fillion a
recueilli les témoignages de nombreux
enfants de parents séparés lors des cent
sont révélateurs ma tête va éclater j'ai
trop de questions dit mode elle a une
grosse state
l'enfant est au coeur de tout ça soyez
témoins des disputes de ses parents soit
il est utilisé comme messager ce qui est
vraiment difficile
soit il n'y a ni l'autre mais il va
devenir ce qu'on appelle le médiateur
naturel c'est à dire que il voit que ses
parents se parlent pas et à des
informations importantes qu'il pense que
ça devrait dit à l'un ou à l'autre
et souvent il prend soin de ses parrains
vous êtes séparés non pas moi ça va rien
changer
c'est plate la séparation oui c'est vrai
ces ateliers ne sont pas un gage de
réussite et exige des parents une bonne
dose d'humilité une maîtrise des
émotions dans la communication il faut
être deux pour communiquer alors on a
des parents qui viennent seuls aux
ateliers on recommande aux parents de
venir tous les deux mais est-ce qu'ils
ont eux aussi encourager ce que des
parents qui viennent seuls et qu'ils
nous ont dit dans l'évaluation qu'ils
avaient retiré des outils pour aborder
l'autre et de s'assurer finalement que
l'autre est disponible et prête à nous
recevoir ou à nous écouter pensées mes
enfants dans dix quinze ans qu'est ce
qu'ils vont dire de
la jeunesse ce qu'ils vont dire que oui
mon usine est et le pire jeunesse que
juge ne peut pas être pire parce que ma
main au pacte est au tapis sa part c'est
pas bien et puis je les ai faites de
mauvaise humeur ou est ce que tu veux
qu'ils se souviennent sans dépasser mes
parents quand j'avais 6 ans mais c'est
sous fabien j'ai une belle jeunesse
maman avait pas été plus heureux
[Musique]